in Lübben in Brandenburg hat die Stadt
direkt am Bahnhof diesen neuen Parkplatz
gebaut Berufspendler sollen hier ihr
Auto abstellen und dann mit der Bahn
weiterfahren aber auf den 105
Stellplätzen herrscht gähnende Lehre
denn der Parkplatz hat eine
entscheidende Nachteil es gibt keine
direkte Verbindung zu den Bahnsteigen
wer hier parkt muss noch mal 10 Minuten
laufen
es ist wenn man so sagen darf es ist
wirklich es nervt es nervt einfach und
gerade weil wir auf Pendler angewiesen
sind also wir müssen häufig pendeln dann
muss man mit dem Koffer und dem ganzen
Gepäck bis zum Bahnhof rumlaufen das
kann man älteren Leuten nicht zumuten
und das ist
das ist auch nicht zeitgemäß
2021 beginnt die Stadt mit der Sanierung
des bahnhofsumfeldes neue Fahrradständer
werden aufgestellt dazu kommt eine
öffentliche Toilette der gesamte Bereich
wird barrierefrei umgebaut hinterm
Bahnhof entsteht der dringend benötigte
Pendlerparkplatz Gesamtkosten 3,4
Millionen Euro doch seit der Eröffnung
sind die Parkplätze immer noch frisch
und unbenutzt der Grund vom Parkplatz
muss man erstmal 400 Meter entlang der
Schienen laufen am Bahnübergang warten
und auf der anderen Seite die 400 m
wieder zurück darauf hat keine Lust
wir brauchen ein Parkplatz weil der
Parkplatz hier ist permanent voll und
die Leute parken dann träume im
Wohngebiet also ja aber es ist einfach
nicht gut geplant denke ich ja das ist
einfach total Blödsinn also keiner nutzt
den Vergleich also geplant ist
eigentlich dass die Pendler durch eine
Unterführung auf die Bahnsteige kommen
doch für deren Bau ist die Bahn
zuständig und die lässt sich zeigen im
Lübbener Rathaus wird man um Geduld mit
dem Bau des Parkplatzes sei man den
Vorleistung getreten nun sei die
Deutsche Bahn am Zug wir sind da im
Gespräch und wir sind auch
zuversichtlich dass man im ersten
Quartal 2025 die ersten Maßnahmen sieht
so dass wir 2025 Ende 25 Anfang 26 auch
diesen Bauabschnitt dann abschließen
können die Bahn wiederum verweist auf
umfangreiche umweltprüfungen will sich
nicht auf ein Datum festlegen höchst
unverbindlich heißt es Ziel bleibt die
Unterführung so schnell wie möglich
fertig zu stellen
in Lübben haben viele die Sorge dass das
noch ewig dauern wird
also ich glaube nicht das sind drei
Jahren um was passieren wird weil nee
ist ja bis jetzt auch nichts passiert
man sagt da sattelt dort das Pferd auch
nicht von hinten auf nicht also man muss
erst den Tunnel schaffen dann kann man
das die Parkplätze schaffen aber genauso
hat man es hier nicht geschafft und es
wird wohl noch lange dauern bis die
Berufspendler die neuen Parkplatz direkt
am Bahnhof endlich vernünftig nutzen
können